know this subject actually annoys me
because my voice is about to get
immediately higher
what designed these bags for Trader
Joe's
and Whole Foods they're so badly
designed they always double bag them
always and it's because their handles
are so poorly designed do you not know
how paper Works Whoever has designed
these paper is strong intention really
really weak and sheer like you can tear
paper so easily and look there's already
a little tear in it and and because it's
only glued on the outside it's just
naturally if this is like Anyway pulls
out it wants to tear it wants to do that
tearing motion but if they glued it on
both sides like in the inside and
outside it would only be under tension
because if you're pulling straight on
the paper it's easy it's easy just do it
so much less paper
I should bring
visible reusable I usually do but
sometimes you forget
just fix it please
thank you